i do like edibles yeah
thank you um i i do it i do enjoy
edibles i
also enjoy weed and i mean if we don't
you want to list the things i like i
like um i like mushrooms uh
i'll take some liquid acid every now and
then if you catch me on a thursday
um
i i actually listen i i am a for sure a
weed
guy like i've always i've always liked
weed i'm not a
i'm not a big drinker i find that i
always make bad life decisions when i
drink you know
you might be here with one of yours
tonight but uh
[Laughter]
but you know what i'm saying um i will
say the one thing about weed and
and wheat is way more for those of you
who haven't smoked weed in like 10 years
and you're like i'm gonna try it again
this is not the weed to do that with the
weed you smoked 10 years ago
sure it's so different from the weed
you're going to smoke now
here's the deal like the weeds you smoke
now they shouldn't give it those names
you know like because the names don't
tell you they're like i bought some
alaskan thunder [ __ ] last week i'm like
i can guess what's gonna happen but i
don't know
the weed it's so powerful it should now
the name of the weed should just be what
it's gonna do to you
because there's a couple weeds i would
never buy ever again you know what you
know what wheat i would never buy again
is gets up four times to see if the
oven's on i [ __ ] hate that we
you know you know that when you're
laying in bed you're like did i turn the
oven off i don't know
and then you walk back into your room
and you're like but did i turn it off i
don't know if i turned it off
yeah come on drink a little too much all
right let's get you up
don't put don't push yourself on the
table
you've seen worse in 35 years i know you
have
you know how i could tell she's seen way
worse in 35 years
because when i went over i was worried
and i just heard her go get up dumb ass
i was like oh i'm not worried if she's
calling him a dumbass what the [ __ ]
you couldn't do that six months you
couldn't do that 35 years this man's
near death she's like
get the [ __ ] up let's go you're
embarrassing me in front of my friends
you know what i mean
well that was exciting
it was funny i heard a little gunk
and then you went like this oh no
[Laughter]
that was a concern oh no oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah and you had a bird's eye view
of the whole
did he just slip out of the chair
yeah well he was a little front heavy
you know what i mean so
well what happens a lot with the older
white guys is they lose their ass and it
comes to their stomach you know what i
mean
so it becomes a front butt and it's just
like super top heavy you know what i
mean
that's what people ask me why i don't
drink i don't drink because i make bad
life decisions when i drink
um but uh my uh i did i decided i'd
write a song about
why i don't drink um it's filled with
examples from my life
and from my friend's lives about weird
and dumb [ __ ] we've done drunk and it's
called a sweat on drink it's why i don't
drink
i don't drink i don't drink
out in the woods drinking mad dog 2020
with
my friends or anyone who drank this
will you sure know how this ends
my friend dropped his pants and he said
do you want to see
a trick and then i saw a grown-up roast
a marshmallow with his dick
that's why i don't drink i don't drink
i don't drink
and have you ever gotten a dragon tattoo
have you ever woke up with a mystery
bruise
have you ever accidentally
pooped
and have you ever eaten chicken nuggets
out of your shoes
that's why i don't drink i don't drink
i don't drink
but every night when then the tequila
feels so right
i'll sit at the bar and i'll drink them
down
[Music]
it's also the only time i try
anal with my wife
and that's why i don't drink i don't
drink
i don't drink
and jack daniels makes me wanna start a
fight
my beard's got me running to take a piss
all night
and that 3 a.m dick pic to your ex don't
seem so wrong
until the next morning when you see it
went to your mom
it's why i don't drink i don't drink
i don't drink
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you i um i i i did send a dick pic
to my mom
here's it i'll tell you what man when i
sent it you know when you send a text to
somebody you want to send
text to you almost reached through the
you're like no no no no
but then i was like you know what if i
was going to
accidentally send a dick pic to anybody
in my family
i'm glad it was my mom i'm going to tell
you why i'll tell you what
because here's a couple reasons one not
just because i like weird [ __ ] which i
do
and not just because she's the funniest
person that could have gotten it
because she is but the real reason i was
okay with sending it to her is that [ __ ]
she's such a supportive person you know
what i mean like
she's never said anything bad about any
of her kids ever
the worst thing i'm gonna get is a text
back like that looks great honey you
know what i mean
so i was like cool you know then she
ghosted me for four hours
i almost sent her a text like have you
seen my dick or what
but then she sent me back maybe the
worst text i could have
ever gotten she sent me back a text that
said
what is that
yo i almost texted my dad like hey man
send me a picture of your dick like what
why doesn't mom know what a dick looks
like i don't understand
are you packing a hammer like what the
[ __ ] is going on
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]